hi everyone how are you doing if you
don't know who I am I've run this
channel along with my best friend Silas
and it's been an absolute blast so this
video is gonna be very short and sweet
for you guys I hope for those of you who
enjoy the content here on the channel
where we've been for the last two months
and where we're going to be going
forwards with the channel there gonna be
a lot of big changes along with a couple
things I'd like to express get off my
chest so the last two months if you
don't know I run a Star Wars Channel as
well along with another few channels and
it's been an extremely busy time for
Star Wars right the last couple months
if you do or don't know it's been the
episodic conclusion to the nine films of
Star Wars with the rise of Skywalker so
now that that's done and Star Wars is
leveling off again it's just more of a
quiet time which is great I have more
time to focus on other things we can
finally get back to making videos
however one thing that you should know
is that Warner Bros really doesn't like
it when you use clips they more maybe
they do like it actually cuz they
copyright your your videos and you don't
get paid for them so going forwards
we're going to be using clips we are
totally ok with being copyrighted we
just want to make content we are Harry
Potter heads
we're Harry Potter fans and we just love
making connaissez this is actually how
we unwind an escape we don't get to make
cool videos and escape to a magical
world so for me and Silas Silas and
myself we loved Harry Potter since we
were kids and you're growing up you know
I was the same age as Harry as I was
reading the books and is it was a
magical time no pun intended it really
was so for me making content and being
able to kind of distance myself from
Star Wars sometimes and make Harry
Potter stuff is very very it's just a
nice feeling it's it's a good break
sometimes and it keeps me refreshed for
both fandoms so going forwards the
contents gonna be a lot more engaging
for you and I hope you'll enjoy it
because there won't just be like boring
little clips anymore regardless of us
getting paid we don't care about that we
just want to make content and have fun
with it regardless of some of the shade
that we've actually been thrown since
the beginning of starting this channel
from other Harry Potter channels that I
didn't know existed which is beautiful
that's great you know but
I guess just like the Star Wars youtuber
world there are so many of them and
they're also quite a few Harry Potter
channels as well my apps should have
done my research but I didn't think it
was important but a lot of them you know
would say things like oh you're a
sellout like you're just making money
here trying to make money it's like we
don't really get any views to begin with
and from a fellow youtuber I'm doing the
same thing you are so I don't really
think that's warranted however going
forwards I would like to say that we
will be using clips in all our videos
which allow us to get out more content
and get out better content which won't
get paid but we don't care we love
making content we love making videos so
I hope you enjoy the content that's
going to be coming forward there gonna
be a lot more videos we're gonna be a
lot more encouraged to make videos
because they won't take so long right
because we would have to make like 60 70
images per video otherwise you just you
get copyrighted but now it's a lot more
easy you just throw some clips on there
and it's a lot more visual stimuli
stimulating and it makes more sense
allows you to connect more with the
viewer as you're watching and telling
the story of why these things happen and
this and that so please in the comments
let me know if there are any videos you
guys are like us to cover
we're always you know thinking up new
ideas searching the internet for like
commonly asked idea ask topics and stuff
like that questions that people may have
and then doing our research if we don't
know or we do know and it's just a
beautiful process it's it's a lovely
enjoyment and pastime for us so I hope
you took something away from this little
update where we've been I'm sorry if we
haven't made any content for the last
two months but it is what it is and
going forwards we're gonna be full-steam
okay thank you very much for listening
and I'll see you in the next video bye